[Musique]
moi j'arrive à cinquantaine à peu près
heures par semaine ça représente à peu
près où on va dire à peu près 1000 euros
les cours sont mal payés alors on est
obligé de faire autant d'heures pour
s'en sortir à peu près voilà on n'a pas
de patron d'arrière et puis on a
sollicité de travailler quand on veut la
journée a commencé à 9 heures elle se
finit à deux heures du matin ça sonne
salive
on travaille la nuit la journée sous la
pluie sur la neige
les clients ne voyais pas mais c'est
très compliqué quand même on est au
détail assez aspi dont la 35 minute
exactement pour livrer la personne sinon
à des pénalités
les clients nous très très mal souvent
là on est noté des petites insultes si
on n'atteint pas bon pourcentage on peut
arrêter du jour au lendemain